- [Instructor] This is
the Khan Academy exercise
on relative maxima and minima,
and they ask us to mark all
the relative maximum points
in the graph.
Like always, pause this video
and see if you can figure out
which are the relative maximum points.
Okay, now let's work
through this together.
And just as a review, a
relative maximum point
is a point of the graph
where the values of the
graph around it are going
to be less than or equal to the value
of the graph at that point.
So, for example, this
point right over here
would not be a relative maximum point,
because if we were to
go to the right of it,
the function is larger than at this point.
It has a higher value than at this point.
This point over here, which
looks like a peak of a mountain,
and that's a pretty good giveaway
if it looks like the top of a
hill or a peak of a mountain
for a form of relative maximum point.
This looks like a really good candidate.
If we move to the right a little bit,
we get lower values for our function,
and if we move to the left a little bit,
and so this is a relative maximum point.
Let's do another example.
Here they say mark all the
relative minimum points
in the graph.
Well, a relative minimum
point is a point of the graph
where if were to look at the
values of the graph around it,
they're all going to
be the same or higher.
One way to think about it,
this would be the bottom
of a dip in the graph.
And you see one big dip in this graph,
and the bottom of it is right over there,
so that would be a relative minimum point.
And you can see if you have
the X values around it,
the values of the function at
those X values are all going
to be the same or higher
than the value of the
function right at this point.
That's not true for
any of the other points
that we can see of this graph.